we've been getting great responses from
our challenge so we thought we would
issue another one and this one will be
fun because it's something that you can
make as fancy as you want but even maybe
a beginning programmer might be able to
do something quite fun and interesting
and who knows we might discover
something new a new contribution to
human knowledge the goal of this
challenge and like all other challenges
if you go to the challenge and I'll
provide the link there's a video
explaining it a little bit more detail
but it's really to visualize patterns
and numbers in new and unexpected ways
discover a new pattern or maybe there
are existing patterns that people know
about but you can visualize it in a way
that we never expected and the one that
I give an example is an alarm spiral
discovered by olam where you spiral out
the numbers and that you'd you and
there's different ways to depict it the
size of the dot is dependent on how many
factors it has here it's the inverse to
the number of factors they have we can
use animation you can use color you can
use whatever it doesn't have to be
spirals it could be tiles you might want
to do something in three dimensions who
knows that's what's fun about these
challenges the you will surprise
everyone else and so I encourage you to
try this challenge create new number
patterns if you want you can build off
of the code that's already there or you
could delete all of it and try to
explore other number patterns you could
expose us to number of patterns that we
might not be aware of that might have
been discovered by someone maybe not
hola whatever it is please try I guess
just just do something that surprises us